yes we could try a Scandinavian
Jarrid MW chess is the opponent let's go
home
yeah
you
I see that comment is Magnus playing or
is he scared of me huh okay I'm thinking
about this
mmm they're probably just as fast with
getting in d4 although no no no no no no
let me maybe try for at least this
movement on here and then this yeah see
I with these early decisions what I'm
trying to do is make sure this pawn
cannot exchange itself up and it will be
forever
vulnerable target this nice this Knight
also feels a bit more secure now that
there's a pawn on c4 no fear of a pin
what would I like to do next something
atypical I think
a knight on the edge I think is a good
plan
ties in well with my big plan which is
to say control deform
a big hole in whites position
now I'm giving up on this idea to knock
out the knight to increase my control
over d4 I think I can I could do without
a bishop here investment
so here we are now we sneak in these
other natural moves
and I think enjoy this position from
here really let's get the light squared
guy working he's there in time
can I take advantage of a rook if it's
promoted to e5
I think so let's just develop and defend
my night
you
this is even a move maybe maybe I'm okay
with working around this guy give him a
kick no no I like my position clean here
how annoying would that move be I don't
know
direct sight up at the heart of the
Kings side
is that a good idea
you
I think what I want to do is
[Music]
is take some time out to oh no no no no
no no no no let's just go here I was
thinking about this with Queen here but
I like the idea to simply focus still on
d4 be welcome to a dark square bishop
exchange we have just that and I'm also
now eyeing up
goodnight versus bad Bishop scenarios
which I you pretty much can force and
I'm gonna maybe go for this still taking
with the piece and now still with an eye
on this stuff oh I had a fork if I would
have maybe put some thought into that
last move better thought instead of this
no but alright move should still be
coming in pretty fast so this let's just
I don't know let's keep the Knights
around for a little bit
yeah let's go back yeah okay let's go
here I'm always gonna be better here
pretty sure
I had I had better I don't that I think
this will be defended
I gotta get everybody there they're
playing extremely fast
yep
let's get my king playing ball
now going here will
I don't know let's just go here
hmm it's tough to contest the h-file if
it opens up because of this tough guy
right
multiple flanks I don't think my King is
on the greatest square in the world just
take now
no that's really the best approach and I
find out okay
let's go here
you
um not really the greatest approach what
I'm doing here
I reckon back off okay
my king just did a little bit of a
circle there okay let's take now and
then go here
prepared to take if it's defended I
think they have to resolve this tension
first there is a pin and an attack and I
still have this move actually
let's do it
and also go here and this Bishop is
nearly dead
nearly
[Music]
okay I think there's enough play over
here
where
[Music]
yeah let's scoot over where's the king
gather they're kind of completely tied
down
and chops the pawn they're getting a
pawn back I could force the rook off
check her mates
it's still dead King here is no help
let's give the check I have this square
and I'm pushing through
I should have landed the fork there
instead of having to do these this
technical squeeze but I guess still
winning
throughout
all right a resigner
you